six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller from the
three one four area code caller what's
your name and where you're calling from
hi my name is spear and I'm from st.
Louis but I'm calling from Chicago
y'alright what's on your mind today so a
couple weeks ago there is a caller who
talked about how some people on the
progressive wean were stagnant Lee
against the Russian allegations most
mobile you guys talk about calcio and
see a secular talk and as a regular
watcher of his show I just let you to
clear up a why people I can feel that
way in what your thoughts are on it so
you're you you want to explain why some
people think there's no connection
between Trump Russia and that the entire
thing is bogus that's what you want to
clear up I guess hmm yes sort of at the
end of all right well I mean you get
with that and you give us the quick
version of it yeah of course all right
so the biggest argument is that Bernie
would have won is they the DNC had we
good because we learn from the WikiLeaks
files having not rigged the primaries in
multiple ways against Bernie Sanders you
know how they played with four times and
Pro burn districts have a use tactics
such as atheists shaming as houses it
against very Sanders how debbie
Wasserman Schultz talks to Morning Joe
and begged them to cover Hillary Clinton
better or else they talked to her boss
and what verb messages is that but it's
house some Democrats and talking about
rushing elections is so much when Trump
has many over
international conflicts of interest that
and saying that Russia hack the election
is a describe distraction from the
corruption yeah how the DNC does not
want progressive politicians in the
Senate or her presidency so it sounds
like basically what you're saying you
you've not negated any assertions that
have been made about Trump Russia all
you've said is there are other things
you think are more important to focus on
but do so do you agree that you've not
negated any assertion that's ever been
made about Trump Russia no I'm just
saying what like talks how things and I
do want him to cover more of Trump
Russia connections I mean that we've
heard what the incident about Sally
Yates that's pretty crazy and cows not
torrefied a bit I'm concerned about that
well I'm why are we talking about Kyle
kolinsky though I don't understand that
part is this your opinion or are you
just telling me someone else's opinion
I'm just clearing I'm just clearing up
that that you don't understand that you
don't understand why people such as him
on the left are so dispersed so
dismissive of the importance of a Russia
case and that it's distracting from
advancement in the Democratic Party
towards more progressive policies and
it's getting those sorts of issues Oh
got it got it got it so real quick I
never mentioned Kyle kolinsky maybe a
caller did but I never mentioned Kyle
but so yeah and I think it's important
you know we can talk about Trump Russia
and about the need for Democrats to move
to the left I mean we could sort of talk
about both those things so all right
well at least now we know your
interpretation of what Kyle kolinsky
thinks about why the Trump Russia thing
maybe is less important than some other
people think and that that's relevant
information I think to some degree so I
really really really appreciate the call
on that note let's take a break and
we'll be back with more after this